[Musique]
ces mouvements qui sont très différents
qui s'opposent pas aux mêmes choses
parfois c'est contre des dictatures
parfois c'est uniquement contre la vie
chère parfois c'est contre un système
économique dans tous ses mouvements et
chacun des points communs et les points
communs c'est qu'il semblait y avoir une
stratégie commune et cette stratégie
commune et bien elle trouve une origine
dans les écrits d'un homme qu'on connaît
pas tellement du grand public isabelle
jean sharp qui est mort en 2010 8 en
janvier 2018 et qui est un philosophe et
qui a beaucoup travaillé dans les années
1970 sur la question de la non violence
comment on part la non violence on peut
renverser des régimes autoritaires
totalitaire des dictatures
alors selon lui la non violence est le
meilleur moyen parce que d'abord la
violence ne peut pas permettre de
renforcer de renverser ces mouvements
selon lui parce que la violence elle est
asymétrique la force est asymétrique les
pouvoirs sont bien plus puissants parce
qu'ils ont les armes et notamment
l'armée que la foule est donc c'est pas
par le moyen d'un affrontement violent
que la foule peut même si elle est plus
importante en nombre peut renverser un
pouvoir dans qui l'a théorisée d'abord
dans les années 70 la non violence mais
surtout surtout en 1989 il s'est rendu
compte qu'à tiananmen
le mouvement n'avait pas pris il s'est
rendu compte que le gouvernement chinois
avait réussi à casser un mouvement qui
pourtant pouvait l'emporter et il a eu
cette analyse il il s'est dit c'est
parce que ce mouvement ou manque de
stratégie il n'y a pas de stratégie dans
ce grand mouvement populaire de
tiananmen et dans toute la chine
d'ailleurs en 1989 et c'est à ce moment
là qu'il a commencé à réfléchir à
l'écriture d'un texte qui va naître en
1993 et ce texte s'appelle de la
dictature à la démocratie
et ce petit texte qui fait même pas 100
pages et qui s'achève par 198 conseil
c'est très précis pour réussir une
révolution ce texte là il va commencer à
se diffuser un peu sous le manteau dans
le monde entier à côté d'anne aux
violences
y'a plein de petites choses qu'on
retrouve dans les mouvements
d'aujourd'hui par exemple il ya l'idée
qu'il faut absolument des slogans des
slogans faciles à répéter le dégagisme
dégage dégage qu'on a retrouvé en
tunisie par exemple je sais pas si c'est
directement du jean charest
mais ce que je sais c'est que dans le
texte de dj de jean sharp
il ya vraiment l'idée d'un slogan simple
clair que tout le monde retient et que
tout le monde dit il ya aussi l'idée de
logos par exemple ont servi dans les
années 90 il ya la main tendue le poing
tendu on va retrouver ça aussi dans les
masques de joker aujourd'hui il faut des
signes très clair ou par exemple dans le
mouvement précédent à hong kong que
c'était des parapluies il faut un
élément symbolique qui va symboliser un
peu comme une marque finalement il faut
que votre mouvement révolutionnaire
hills et les même si c'est pas de la pub
mais il faut quand même qu'ils aient des
éléments de reconnaissance qu'on puisse
retrouver dans le monde entier qu'on
puisse dupliquer aussi pour montrer son
attachement à cette révolution en
algérie récemment vous avez eu beaucoup
de slogans avec de l'humour
il faut vraiment qu'on tournait votre
contourner si vous voulez un piège le
piège ce serait que le pouvoir disent
ces gens là sont extrêmement violent
nous sommes du côté de l'ordre
donc nous allons tous les arrêtés et
l'opinion publique la majorité de la
population qui préfèrent l'ordre au
désordre pourrait abandonner les
mouvements populaires ici ou là en
conservant au mouvement populaire sa
fraîcheur son humour sa féminité
son absence de violence il y a la
possibilité qu arrive ce moment
fantastique pour toutes les révolutions
et c'est l'objectif numéro 1 que le gène
sharp a signé à ces révolutions c'est
qu'à un moment donné
l'armée et la police baisse les armes et
aille avec les révoltés ce qu'en ce
moment arrive c'est que la révolution
l'a emporté et ce moment ne peut arriver
que si les soldats ne se font pas à
frapper
s'ils ne se font pas insulter et si au
contraire en face d'eux il ya leurs
femmes
il ya leurs enfants il ya les copains de
leurs enfants avec des signes des
symboles qui l'ont vu partout fleurir
sur les réseaux sociaux et qu'il leur
dise bas peut-être que je suis plus fort
que peut-être que si je le veux exige
obéi aux ordres
je veux les écraser mais j'ai plus
intérêt aujourd'hui parce que c'est
ma dimension d'êtres humains de poser
les armes et d'être avec eux